[Music]
and that's bugs yeah AGI has aspects of
computer science mathematics engineering
philosophy of mind linguistics and
neuroscience it's quite
cross-disciplinary and the education
system isn't it isn't really that way
it's more that way in the u.s. than
anywhere else on the planet actually
that's a strength the US has here here
as an undergraduate you can at least
take courses in every department and in
many countries that that's not true but
even in the u.s. the education system is
not nearly as cross-disciplinary as it
should be for grappling with a problem
like a GI or would say quantum computing
or nanotechnology or a lot of other
cutting-edge things so what that means
is if someone wants to really work and
one of these cutting-edge topics that
has the highest probability of
transforming the world if they want to
work on these things in the core
capacity they have to take their own
time to study a bunch of other fields
that they didn't learn in school and
that also takes time you can't do that
by reading a blog post I mean you got to
you know take out the neuroscience text
spoken and go through it step by step
and not everyone has the patience for
that but again some people do and I'd
say Coursera Udacity and MIT the many
universities that have put their
courseware online have been a huge huge
asset in this process because those
helped lead people through the process
of learning information from all the
different disciplines that they need to
attack something like like a GI what we
found these online courses incredibly
useful what we've been doing in Ethiopia
so in in 2013 I co-founded with two
others
Ethiopia's first a AI and robotics
development company so we do some
original R&D some projects aimed at
helping the African situation than a
bunch of software and
outsourcing companies called I cog labs
based in in August Ababa and we have an
internship program which we use for
recruiting so we take dozens of
undergrad students each year and what we
do we give them some hands-on lessons in
OpenCog and various other AI tools we
also have each of them take like seven
Coursera courses and they go through
them very quickly and they teach them
you know neuroscience computational
linguistics bioinformatics machine
learning a bunch of topics that are not
offered in the university there and this
works much better than giving them a
bunch of text books to read because it
gives them a process in a community to
enter into and not only teaches them
information but it weeds out people who
don't have the persistence to to slog
through stuff from a bunch of different
different disciplines and really stretch
their brain than the in the deeper
deeper cross-disciplinary way so yeah
I'd say as with everything else there's
pluses and minuses all all tangled up
right I mean the modern way of doing
things in some ways eliminates people's
attention span because nobody has to
think for themselves they immediately
look up the answer I'm the only internet
or download something instead of trying
to solve a problem themselves on the
other hand there's so much high-quality
educational material out there together
with supportive communities for people
who do want to want to plunge in deeper
and get a more foundational
understanding cognitive synergy is a
term that I introduced to refer to the
process of multiple cognitive processes
acting on a common knowledge
representation interacting according to
mutual aid rather than just independence
or some sort of competitive
relationships so when when one cognitive
process like reasoning or vision or
creative concept creation gets stuck and
there are so many possibilities in front
of it
tell what to do then it can ask some
other cognitive process to come in and
help it cut through the confusion
creating a collection of cognitive
processes that covers all the bases
needed for human-like intelligence and
that work together in a mutually
supportive synergetic way is not
especially easy and I spent about a
decade working on the technical details
of that in designing the OpenCog system
together with a number of my colleagues
[Music]